Hey guys, it's Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast and I want to welcome you to another somatic Jungian based meditation. We have gotten a lot of requests to do another one since I have an old one and I do those fairly differently now with some principles from Somatic Experiencing by Peter Levin, Process-Oriented Therapy by Arnie Mendel, Voice Dialogue Therapy by Sidra and Hal Stone, and IFS techniques developed by Richard Schwartz. These are largely somatic and post Jungian therapies that build on Jung's insights and you can read more about them on our website if you're interested. We've got a lot of biographies and things on our
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel，欢迎来到又一期基于荣格心理学的躯体冥想。自从我发布了旧版冥想后，收到了很多请求，希望再做一期。我现在的方法有所不同，融入了彼得·莱文（Peter Levin）的躯体体验疗法、阿尼·门德尔（Arnie Mendel）的过程导向疗法、西德拉和哈尔·斯通（Sidra and Hal Stone）的语音对话疗法，以及理查德·施瓦茨（Richard Schwartz）开发的IFS（内在家庭系统）技术。这些主要是基于荣格理论的躯体疗法，如果您感兴趣，可以在我们的网站上阅读更多相关信息。我们的网站上有许多传记和资料，
blog but the therapy meditation that I did on Jungian shadow work was one of the most popular things that we released on YouTube and we got a lot of requests to do another one. So here's an update of how I do those meditations now. You wanna be sure before you start this that you're in a safe space, a comfortable space, nice temperature, well-fitting clothing, and you just somewhere private where you can relax.
博客上也有。但我之前做的关于荣格阴影工作的冥想疗法是我们YouTube上最受欢迎的内容之一，很多人要求再做一期。所以，这是我目前进行此类冥想的更新版。在开始之前，请确保你处于一个安全、舒适的空间，温度适宜，穿着舒适的衣服，并且在一个私密的地方，可以让你放松下来。
There's ambient noise, that's fine. Just make that part of your process of recognizing annoyance as a somatic or a unconscious protective part Any things that might pop up You're never in the perfect place to do a meditation, but you do want to make sure that you're not driving You're not Anywhere it may be dangerous and we'll go ahead and begin that meditation now. So I want you to find a nice to open posture sitting up
如果有环境噪音也没关系。只需将其作为你过程的一部分，将烦躁感识别为一种躯体或潜意识的保护性部分。任何可能出现的情况，你永远无法找到一个完美的冥想场所，但要确保你没有在开车，也不在任何危险的地方。我们现在就开始冥想。我希望你找到一个舒适的姿势，坐着
or lay down if that's comfortable for you. And I want you to just kind of map your psyche for a minute and find the things that you avoid, not just an emotion, but an implicit emotion, a deep relationship between your inside world and your outside world where you feel that you cannot survive, that this is wrong. Maybe it's feeling trapped for you. Maybe it's feeling less good than other people, feeling inferior. Maybe it's feeling powerless, you know, unable to act. It might be powerless like you have to do something but you're not strong enough. And it may be a powerlessness like a paralyzation, like you are wanting to do something but you don't know how, what, or where that kind of action should come from.
或者躺下，如果那样让你觉得舒服的话。我想让你花一分钟时间梳理一下你的心理，找出那些你回避的事物，不仅仅是一种情绪，而是一种内隐的情绪，一种你内心世界与外部世界之间深层的关系，让你觉得无法生存，觉得这是错误的。也许对你来说是感到被困住。也许是觉得自己不如别人，感到自卑。也许是感到无力，你知道，无法采取行动。这可能是一种无力感，就像你必须做点什么，但你不够强大。也可能是一种无力感，就像瘫痪一样，你想做点什么，但不知道该怎么做、做什么，或者这种行动应该从哪里开始。
It could be lots of things. But you want to find that feeling that is the hardest place to go for you. The emotional arc you're either so enmeshed with that you have to feel that way all the time or that you're so avoidant of that you feel like if you feel it you'll die, I can't go back there, you know intellectually you understand most of us do That this is doesn't matter. It shouldn't affect us anymore for lots of reasons, but that intellect is not going to help you here We have to kind of teach your body and your brain stem your
这可能是很多事情。但你要找到那个对你来说最难面对的感觉。那个情绪弧线，要么是你与之纠缠太深，以至于你必须一直那样感受；要么是你如此回避它，以至于你觉得如果感受它你就会死。我无法回到那里，你知道，从理智上讲，我们大多数人都明白这并不重要。由于种种原因，它不应该再影响我们了，但理智在这里帮不上忙。我们必须教导你的身体和脑干，你的
subcortical brain That this is something that you have mastery over now and that you can go back and that you can be overwhelmed and then master this space of emotion. So when you find your traumatic memory, your phobia, your emotional trigger, try and go beneath the event that created it. Don't just try and remember an event that's overwhelming, but turn the event into a state of being that is hard for you. And so don't analyze it and don't think about it intellectually, but just listen to the energy of this thing that is your shadow in your body and see what it activates. See where it is inhabiting the
皮层下大脑，让你明白现在你已经掌握了主动权，你可以回去，你可以被淹没，然后掌控这个情绪空间。所以，当你找到你的创伤记忆、恐惧症或情绪触发点时，试着深入到创造它的事件之下。不要只是试图回忆一个让你不知所措的事件，而是将该事件转化为一种对你来说很困难的存在状态。所以不要分析它，也不要从理智上思考它，只需倾听你身体中作为阴影的能量，看看它激活了什么。看看它在哪里占据得
most intensely. Is it that you feel your spine wanting to curl into a ball to make yourself smaller or to protect yourself with a rigidity? Is it that you are wanting to stand up tall and tight and fight, make yourself larger, less inferior? Or is it just kind of a looseness that you want to wriggle away, you want to move, just don't think about this. Let go and notice what your spine is doing when you inhabit this space and your emotional spectrum. Notice what your hands and your extremities, your fingers, your toes, are they limp or are they tingling? And scan your body for tension and notice if there is tension in your chest, hot or a cold, heavy, a light or a tight feeling.
最强烈。是你感觉到脊椎想要蜷缩成一团，让自己变小，或者用僵硬来保护自己吗？是你想要站得笔直、紧绷，去战斗，让自己变得更高大，减少自卑感吗？还是说这是一种松弛感，你想扭动着逃离，你想移动？只是不要去思考。放手，注意当你处于这个空间和情绪光谱中时，你的脊椎在做什么。注意你的手和四肢，你的手指、脚趾，它们是无力的还是在发麻？扫描你的身体，寻找紧张感，注意你的胸部是否有紧张感，是热还是冷，沉重、轻盈还是紧绷的感觉。
And now notice your stomach. If your guts are locking up, if there's pain, hunger, blankness, scan your jawbone, move your jaw back and forth, left and right. See if there's tension. Sometimes jaw tension shows up creeping from the hinge of the jaw up into the inner ear. If you have TMJ at night, a lot of the times it will show up as an inner ear pain. There's no infection or allergy, but there
现在注意你的胃。如果你的肠胃锁紧，如果有疼痛、饥饿、空白感，扫描你的下颌骨，前后左右移动你的下巴。看看是否有紧张感。有时下颌紧张会从下颌关节蔓延到内耳。如果你晚上有颞下颌关节紊乱（TMJ），很多时候它会表现为内耳疼痛。没有感染或过敏，但
is a pain. Wherever you've noticed these feelings the most across your body, and I'm not there with you in therapy to listen and to zoom in on them, so you have to find them like a map and don't judge them as good or bad, even if they're overwhelming or they're upsetting or just an unpleasant feeling. Just try and turn a curiosity towards them of a kind of sense of wonder of what these things are and what they want. And just let them float there with you for a moment. I want you to notice each somatic feeling at each place that the shadow is showing up
有疼痛感。无论你在身体的哪个部位最明显地注意到这些感觉，我都不在你身边进行治疗，无法倾听并聚焦于它们，所以你必须像看地图一样找到它们，不要评判它们是好是坏，即使它们让你不知所措、心烦意乱或只是不愉快的感觉。试着对它们产生一种好奇心，一种对这些东西是什么以及它们想要什么的惊奇感。让它们和你一起漂浮一会儿。我想让你注意阴影在你的
in your psyche soma, your mind body. I want you to feel each of those spaces. See if you can get temperatures or textures It doesn't have to make intellectual sense VCR static The fizz when you open a coke Kind of dull pressure like a heavy metal object. All of these are perfectly valid things to notice Is there an emptiness a a denseness, a churning? So just sense that energy for a minute. And if there's pain, is it electric? Is it dull? Is it piercing? Is it throbbing?
心理躯体，即你的身心中出现的每一个躯体感觉。我想让你感受每一个空间。看看你是否能感受到温度或质地。它不需要有理智上的意义。录像带的静电声，打开可乐时的嘶嘶声，像重金属物体一样的沉闷压力。所有这些都是完全有效的观察。是否有空虚感、致密感、翻腾感？所以，花一分钟去感受那种能量。如果有疼痛，它是电击般的吗？是钝痛吗？是刺痛吗？是搏动吗？
Is it imploding? Don't stop at just pain. Wonder. Wonder what it is. and stay curious. So we're still in a metacognitive space that is aware of the thing but outside of it. Don't become possessed by it. Don't decide what it means you have to do or what you are, what you have to be. Just let it be and let you be. And while you are being, notice what it is doing. And just curiously feel it for a moment. And I want you to let that somatic sensation, wherever that is showing up, spread. So just give it a minute and when you turn your attention to it, see where it wants to go in your body if it moves. And if it doesn't want to move, see how it wants to move your body. Do you want to move left or right like you're under water in the flow of something? Do you want to pick your hands up
是内爆吗？不要只停留在疼痛上。去惊奇。去惊奇它是什么，并保持好奇。所以我们仍然处于一个元认知空间，意识到这个事物但处于它之外。不要被它占据。不要决定它意味着你必须做什么，或者你是什么，你必须成为什么。让它成为它，让你成为你。当你存在时，注意它在做什么。好奇地感受它一会儿。我想让你让那种躯体感觉，无论它出现在哪里，扩散开来。所以给它一分钟，当你把注意力转向它时，看看它想在你的身体里去哪里，如果它移动的话。如果它不想移动，看看它想如何移动你的身体。你想向左或向右移动，就像你在水下随着某种东西流动一样吗？你想抬起你的手吗？
just let it do what it wants to do and see where it wants to go and you may feel the pain or the tension or the tightness whatever it is move to a new space or connect to another pain that you hadn't noticed was there before another expression noticed was there before. Another expression of your relationship to this feeling, this deep implicit feeling. It is the root of this emotion that you are not good at, that you have a relationship with where it possesses you and tells you what to do instead of you using it and noticing it. And then letting it go when you've heard it. These things want to be heard because they have something to say that we don't listen to. And if you feel it stop, as you notice it move around,
让它做它想做的事，看看它想去哪里。你可能会感觉到疼痛、紧张或紧绷，无论它是什么，移动到一个新的空间，或者连接到另一个你之前没有注意到的疼痛。这是你与这种感觉关系的另一种表达，这种深层的内隐感觉。它是这种你不擅长处理的情绪的根源，你与它有一种关系，它占据了你并告诉你该做什么，而不是你利用它并注意到它。然后在你听到它之后让它离开。这些东西想要被听到，因为它们有我们没有倾听的话要说。如果你感觉到它停止了，当你注意到它四处移动时，
and you feel this process slow down. And you feel where it's settled, if it's moved or changed or connected to other points. Connect, as Arnie Mendel would say, to the visual channel. See if you get an image like a color or a feeling that is not quite visual like you're in a field or an outer space or in a room and just notice all of the cosmology that this thing feels around you.
你感觉到这个过程慢了下来。你感觉到它定居在哪里，如果它移动、改变或连接到其他点。正如阿尼·门德尔所说，连接到视觉通道。看看你是否能得到一个图像，比如一种颜色，或者一种不太视觉化的感觉，就像你在田野里、外太空中或房间里，只需注意这个东西在你周围感觉到的所有宇宙观。
And even if it's unpleasant or overwhelming or upsetting, just stay with it. With curiosity, keep a curiosity tuned and open to see what happens next. Because we're not going to stay here forever. You may have memories come back, usually not, but sometimes we do. If you get a color, remember that color. And now turn your attention to the auditory channel. And on the auditory channel, I want you to see if you notice anything that feels like a sound.
即使它是不愉快的、不知所措的或令人心烦的，也要坚持下去。保持好奇心，保持好奇心并开放，看看接下来会发生什么。因为我们不会永远待在这里。你可能会有记忆回来，通常不会，但有时会。如果你得到一种颜色，记住那种颜色。现在把你的注意力转向听觉通道。在听觉通道上，我想让你看看你是否注意到任何感觉像声音的东西。
And sometimes it's like the energy of where a sound would be. Not quite something we hear, but something that we have in. And those are important too. They're part of your relationship to this part of self that you are not in good relationship with. Notice if words arise, idea words, big words, mythy words, little words. Even if they're weird or strange and you wonder why that's in your head or you think you're doing it wrong, you're not. Just remember those colors and sounds and visual sound- memories, and visual memories of what the world is like around you. And try and amplify it.
有时它就像声音所在位置的能量。不完全是我们听到的东西，而是我们拥有的东西。这些也很重要。它们是你与这个你关系不好的自我部分之间关系的一部分。注意是否有词语出现，观念词、大词、神话词、小词。即使它们很奇怪，你不知道为什么它们会在你的脑海里，或者你认为你做错了，你没有。只需记住那些颜色、声音和视觉声音记忆，以及你周围世界是什么样子的视觉记忆。并试着放大它。
If you feel scared, like you're a mouse in a field hiding from a hawk, I want you to get scareder. And if you feel icky, like you shouldn't be here, like it's a place that you shouldn't see or you shouldn't allow yourself to make yourself feel worse, feel that ick. Give it more of a visual or sonic character, is it like a slime, does it appear like a glop or a hiss? You feel like you're not wanted here.
如果你感到害怕，就像田野里躲避老鹰的老鼠，我希望你更害怕。如果你感到恶心，就像你不应该在这里，就像这是一个你不应该看到的地方，或者你不应该让自己感觉更糟，感受那种恶心。给它更多的视觉或声音特征，它像粘液吗，它看起来像一团东西还是嘶嘶声？你觉得你不被欢迎在这里。
Try and amplify all parts of this memory, the sense of space around you, visual images, auditory images, and somatic experiencing of what they do to your body. And I want you to enhance that image and make it more vivid. And if it morphs into kind of a metaphor that doesn't quite fit, just let that be. It doesn't have to fit into language. A lot of these things don't fit into language. I mean the shadow starts to disappear when you look at it. Shrink back into different shapes. Just turn it into a metaphor. Are you a teapot about to explode? Are you an empty dry well with nothing left? Are you a cosmonaut in
试着放大这段记忆的所有部分，你周围的空间感、视觉图像、听觉图像以及它们对你身体造成的躯体体验。我想让你增强那个图像，让它更生动。如果它演变成一种不太合适的隐喻，那就让它那样吧。它不需要符合语言。很多这些东西都不符合语言。我的意思是，当你看着阴影时，它就开始消失。缩回不同的形状。把它变成一个隐喻。你是一个即将爆炸的茶壶吗？你是一个什么都不剩的干枯水井吗？你是一个在
space who's drifting watching the earth get smaller and smaller in blackness. And come back to the intellect for a minute, we need that too. And think about what these images that you're conjuring mean for your relationship to this emotion. Start to understand the specific ways that it overwhelms you, that it takes away your agency and that you mistake it for yourself instead of a part of you. And start to notice these other healthy parts that want to protect you from the shadow that say it isn't true, that say it isn't real anymore, that say you wouldn't make these mistakes again, you couldn't because you know more. And try and thank them if they come up for their compassion and their need to protect
太空中漂流的宇航员，看着地球在黑暗中变得越来越小。回到理智一会儿，我们也需要那个。思考一下你所唤起的这些图像对于你与这种情绪的关系意味着什么。开始理解它让你不知所措的具体方式，它夺走了你的代理权，你把它误认为是你自己，而不是你的一部分。并开始注意到这些想要保护你免受阴影伤害的健康部分，它们说这不是真的，它们说它不再真实了，它们说你不会再犯这些错误了，你不能，因为你知道得更多。如果它们出现，试着感谢它们的同情心和保护你的需要。
you. Let them know that you're here to listen to the shadow and it's not going to overpower you. And let those protective parts relax a little bit because you need to hear them too. And now return to this shadow sensation and this metaphor that we've made with our visual and our auditory and our social and our idea based memory and our linguistic memory And notice how time doesn't quite make sense To each of these things or it does make sense, but differently Some have never changed
让它们知道你在这里倾听阴影，它不会压倒你。让那些保护性的部分放松一点，因为你也需要倾听它们。现在回到这个阴影感觉和我们用视觉、听觉、社交和基于观念的记忆以及语言记忆所做的隐喻。注意时间是如何不完全适用于这些东西的，或者它确实适用，但方式不同。有些从未改变
Ever and then others are changing all the time. And feel that sense of time as kind of a strange thing where parts of you are disagreeing about what is relevant in your felt sense of being and make space for this wounded part of you that was so scary at the beginning to be felt and seen and heard and even if it's distressing or upsetting or overwhelming try and have empathy that it thinks that this is all you are and can do and can be and have some validation that it thinks what it's doing is important and necessary and also try and accept how powerful this has been for so long.
过，而另一些则一直在变化。感受那种时间感，这是一种奇怪的事情，你身体的某些部分对于什么是相关的存在感有分歧。为这个在开始时如此可怕的受伤部分腾出空间，让它被感受、被看见、被听到。即使它令人痛苦、心烦意乱或不知所措，也要试着去同情它，因为它认为这就是你的全部，你只能做这些，只能成为这样。并对它认为自己所做的事情是重要和必要的给予一些认可，同时也试着接受这种力量在这么长时间里是多么强大。
This wasn't a perspective that we had a couple minutes ago. But we always knew deep down that there was something else. Don't look for solutions or answers or even words. And when you do that, see if those spaces in your body have started to shift or unfold or move and if they're in the same spots that's fine. And if the energy is slightly different it has a different character like a tiredness or sometimes the pain that we get when chronic tension resolves. There's adult ache that's left. Or just the kind of little spikes as enzymes discharge and muscles when we pay attention to them and we feel little involuntary movements and tremors. Any of that is And I want you to take deep breaths.
这不是我们几分钟前有的视角。但我们内心深处一直知道还有别的东西。不要寻找解决方案或答案，甚至不要寻找词语。当你这样做时，看看你身体里的那些空间是否已经开始转变、展开或移动。如果它们在同一个位置，那没关系。如果能量略有不同，它有不同的特征，比如疲劳，或者有时慢性紧张消除时我们得到的疼痛。留下的是一种成人的酸痛。或者只是当我们在关注肌肉时，酶在肌肉中释放产生的小刺痛，我们感觉到轻微的不自主运动和颤抖。任何这些都是。我希望你深呼吸。
And fuel your body and your sense of consciousness as a whole thing again. That is not deconstructed, that is back together. These things are like balls of yarn, they activate these separate types of memory. We have to untangle it and wind the whole ball back together. It doesn't fix anything. It's still there. But we saw, we start to see what it's connected to. And how long it's going to take to unwind all of these things and put them back together to be a memory that we understand from
再次为你的身体和你的意识整体提供能量。它没有被解构，而是重新组合在一起。这些东西就像毛线球，它们激活了这些不同类型的记忆。我们必须解开它，把整个球重新绕在一起。它不能解决任何问题。它仍然在那里。但我们看到了，我们开始看到它与什么相连。以及解开所有这些东西并将它们重新组合成一个我们从
all angles not just as an instrument an overwhelming thing. Wiggle your toes and your fingers across your arms across your chest, rub your heart, the texture of your shirt, clothing, and then open your arms wide. And put your arms slowly up over your head like a snow angel. And then make one foot point and reach all the way down. And then the other foot point and reach all the way down like a ballerina standing on tiptoe. And then take your spine and wiggle it back and forth like you're a snake. And then wiggle it front
各个角度理解的记忆需要多长时间，不仅仅是作为一个工具，一个压倒性的东西。动动你的脚趾和手指，穿过你的手臂，穿过你的胸部，揉揉你的心脏，感受衬衫、衣服的质地，然后张开双臂。把你的手臂慢慢举过头顶，像做雪天使一样。然后让一只脚尖点地并一直向下伸展。然后另一只脚尖点地并一直向下伸展，就像踮着脚尖站立的芭蕾舞演员。然后用你的脊椎像蛇一样来回扭动。然后扭动它，从前
to back and let the wiggle run all the way down your spine in a ripple like you're a dolphin front to back and let the wiggle run all the way down your spine in a ripple like you're a dolphin front to back swimming now we've kind of moved some things and we've unlocked a lot and the somatic energy may have shifted so we want to bring it all back to the center scan the body and see what's different. And if there's places that feel cold or hot or in pain, what we're looking for is different. That's not bad.
到后，让扭动像涟漪一样沿着你的脊椎一直向下，就像你是一只海豚，从前到后，让扭动像涟漪一样沿着你的脊椎一直向下，就像你是一只海豚，从前到后游泳。现在我们已经移动了一些东西，我们已经解锁了很多，躯体能量可能已经转移了，所以我们想把它全部带回中心。扫描身体，看看有什么不同。如果有些地方感觉冷或热或疼痛，我们寻找的是不同的东西。那并不坏。
If it's different than how you started. And there may still be some things left and it may be good to repeat the meditation again. But we don't want to do too much at once. We just want to feel these little changes and start to map out this place beneath different pieces of sensation. So now open your eyes slowly and look at the world around you and notice that it is different, that you feel different. And different is good. And we don't have to understand everything that happened right away. But it's normal for realizations and memories to surface. It's normal for you to notice your relationship to this emotion being a different thing that you can catch a little bit early, that your shoulders are
如果它和你开始时不同。可能还有一些东西留下，再次重复冥想可能是有益的。但我们不想一次做太多。我们只想感受这些微小的变化，并开始在不同的感觉片段下绘制这个地方。所以现在慢慢睁开眼睛，看看你周围的世界，注意到它是不同的，你感觉不同了。不同是好的。我们不必马上理解发生的一切。但实现和记忆浮出水面是正常的。你注意到你与这种情绪的关系变成了一种不同的东西，你可以早一点捕捉到它，你的肩膀在
tight when you're angry, or that your posture doesn't stand up straight or that you slouch or you hunch or you tighten your arms when you feel threatened or something. And just look for those changes as you repeat this meditation and come back to it whenever it's helpful, whenever you have time. And now it's never quite the same. Well, thank you for joining me for the meditation. And we will try and get some more of these out soon because it's been requested quite a bit. Hey guys, I wanted to pop in here to give you a quick reminder that we do this podcast for free and there are significant expenses associated with it, including the biggest resource of my life right now, which is time. One of the things that would really help us, and hopefully would help you, would be to
生气时很紧，或者你的姿势没有站直，或者当你感到受威胁或什么的时候，你会弯腰驼背或收紧手臂。当你重复这个冥想时，寻找这些变化，并在任何有帮助的时候，任何你有时间的时候回到它。现在它从来都不完全一样。好吧，谢谢你加入我的冥想。我们会尽量尽快发布更多此类内容，因为很多人都要求这样做。嘿，大家好，我想在这里插一句，提醒大家我们免费制作这个播客，并且与之相关的开支很大，包括我现在生活中最大的资源，那就是时间。真正能帮助我们，也希望对你有帮助的一件事，就是
check out one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. Hardy is a vitamin company that I never encountered the advertising of. We heard over and over again from multiple people with treatment-resistant anxiety and dopamine disorders like bipolar disorder and other things that they had tried everything and Hardy was what worked. And so I checked them out and they have really good research. I'm not a fan of a lot of the BS that's in the supplement and wellness space.
看看我们的赞助商之一，Hardy Nutritionals。Hardy是一家维生素公司，我从未遇到过他们的广告。我们一次又一次地从多个患有难治性焦虑症和多巴胺障碍（如双相情感障碍等）的人那里听说，他们尝试了一切，而Hardy是有效的。所以我查看了他们，他们有非常好的研究。我不喜欢补充剂和健康领域中很多胡说八道的东西。
Hardy paid for a lot of research on their product. And when I ordered some for myself, I saw a big difference in my life. And my wife made fun of me, thought it was gonna be Alex Jones selling vitamins on the radio. And when she tried them, she really liked them too. There's a lot of data about how they can reduce the symptoms of ADHD without medications or lower your need
Hardy为他们的产品支付了大量的研究费用。当我为自己订购了一些时，我看到了我生活中巨大的变化。我妻子取笑我，以为是亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）在电台上卖维生素。当她尝试它们时，她也非常喜欢它们。有很多关于它们如何在不使用药物的情况下减少多动症（ADHD）症状或降低你对
for medication, also manage some of the effects of autism spectrum disorder and a whole lot of other things. Newer research around nutrition is saying that the synergistic effects of multiple things being planned to work together is a lot more effective than one thing working alone. You can get a lot of information about that on our website. Or you can head over to GetHardy, that's G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y and use offer code TAPROOT for 15% off. It would help them, it would help me, and it also would probably help you. One of the more frequent things that patients and people in the randomized controlled trials that Hardy conducted report is that they feel more themself, more focused and more effective at getting things done, which can result in all of us having a little
药物的需求，以及管理自闭症谱系障碍的一些影响和许多其他事情的数据。关于营养的最新研究表明，多种事物协同工作比单一事物单独工作要有效得多。你可以在我们的网站上获得很多关于这方面的信息。或者你可以前往GetHardy，即G-E-T-H-A-R-D-Y，并使用优惠码TAPROOT享受15%的折扣。这会帮助他们，帮助我，也可能会帮助你。Hardy进行的随机对照试验中的患者和人们报告的最常见的事情之一是，他们感觉更像自己，更专注，更有效地完成事情，这可以导致我们所有人都有
bit more time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一点更多的时间。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。